[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais de notre vie nous ne verrons
autant de deux sur nos calendriers ce
mardi nous sommes le 22 02 2022 et cela
fait beaucoup parler parce qu'il s'agit
d'un palindrome une date qui peut se
lire dans les deux sens mais aussi à
l'envers parce qu'en plus c'est un
ambigramme c'est déjà pas mal mais
beaucoup attendent ce soir 22h22
précises pour compléter le tableau c'est
vrai que tout le monde change tout le
temps c'est
vrai que cette ce changement est violent
[Musique]
les réseaux sociaux avant quand quand
Weber l'ouvrait au café du commerce et
du lui-même qu'il disait ta gueule bébé
en question se précipite sur
l'ordinateur une pensée de mes couilles
est 17 fautes d'orthographe ça y est
c'est parti donc c'est extraordinaire
mais c'est ce qui marrant parce que
c'est le monde qu'on vit la station des
Deux Alpes surf sur le phénomène sans
trop se mouiller elle offrira 22 ans
d'abonnement gratuit à des jumeaux nés
ce soir entre 22 et 23 heures
qu'est-ce qui juste à côté du volcan de
l'Etna en fusion donc en Italie hier ce
nuage de fumée qu'on voit ici et de
cendres qui a été produit par le volcan
on peut skier un autre endroit c'est
vrai et quand même ce nuage il a
contraint l'aéroport de Katan a
interrompre son trafic trafic qui a
depuis un progressivement repris à moins
de deux semaines de la clôture des
inscriptions trois des candidats à la
présidentielle parmi les mieux placés
dans les sondages peine à rassembler les
500 parrainages Éric Zemmour en a obtenu
291 Jean-Luc Mélenchon 370 et Marine Le
Pen en est à 366 ce matin Marine Le Pen
détaillait son programme sur RTL oui
d'ailleurs vous mesurez combien Marine
Le Pen un mètre 75 donc avec des talents
de 10 cm
je le note mais ouh là là non alors là
c'est pas possible je crois qu'il y a un
petit ortier qui veut dire
il est en train de faire la voiture
un dinosaure sur un fil bienvenue dans
l'univers d'elgastenzell une artiste
basée à Londres pour qui étendre le
linge n'est pas une corvée mais une
source d'inspiration et cela commence
dès le lavage ces animaux ont fait de
chaussettes t-shirt et pantalons elle
les crée dans son jardin et grâce à un
montage photo il se retrouve dans leur
environnement naturel mais à moins de
deux mois du premier tour la question
que tout le monde se pose est évidemment
ou Marine Le Pen achète-t-elle ses
vêtements
non mais vous savez moi j'achète pas mal
de mes habits sur vinted
mais je suis sûr que je ne suis pas le
seul à crever d'envie de savoir est-ce
qu'elle revend également sur vinted vous
revendez aussi sur vintage oui oui ça
m'arrive quand j'ai le temps moi en ce
moment pas trop bien belle campagne
président
[Applaudissements]
génial Matteo tu vois on pleure et après
on rigole
alors c'est la vérité ça vous fait rire
en plus
franchement avec le match pitoyable que
vous nous offrir un peu d'humidité ne
ferai pas de mal
quand je n'avais pas la barbe avec
la barbe un acteur que j'ai découvert
d'ailleurs il s'appelle Jason Statham
mais oui mais c'est ça Jason Statham
regardez c'est bluffant on a où et
Jean-Michel où est Jason plus pire on
est dans un match nul dans tous les sens
du terme on est d'accord donc si vous
aussi vous êtes nuls sachez que c'est
possible de venir sur ce plateau
exactement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
voici les seules images du nouvel album
de Kanye West Donda 2
pas de clip juste un petit appareil
appelé steamplayer pour écouter ses
chansons il faut acheter ce lecteur de
musique qu'il a lui-même créé avec sa
société
c'est la musique et Robert bon vous êtes
un poil agaçant je me permets de vous
dire parce que vous savez tout faire
vous jouez de la comédie vous jouez de
la guitare vous jouez du piano vous
savez chanter et quand vous étiez plus
jeune vous rêviez d'être rappeur vous
aviez même un pseudo big tube qui ne fit
pas vraiment la même chose en français
je laisse la traduction faire le travail
mais en anglais je veux dire autre chose
avec cet objet de consommateur peut
remixer les morceaux ajoutez des effets
[Musique]
enlever la voix du chanteur retirez des
pistes audio être en quelque sorte un
mini compositeur une révolution dans le
monde musical et un pied de nez au
plateformes de diffusion et maison de 10
aujourd'hui les artistes ne reçoivent
que 12 % de l'argent que l'industrie
gagne il est temps de libérer la musique
de ce système oppressif si vous ne
trouvez pas ne serait-ce que un mot elle
n'a même pas besoin de chanter puisque
en cas d'égalité elle resterait maestro
d'accord et là on est plus dans un match
nul on est dans une émission nulle
depuis tout à l'heure j'ai envie de
faire un truc d'enfant vraiment c'était
une bêtise quoi vraiment c'est mais je
crève d'envie le médecin
que ça va vous mettre un tout petit peu
dans la merde j'ai un tout petit peu
envie de voir
s'il vous plaît
j'appelle la police
vous voyez il est chaud mais il sent le
brûler ce qui est étrange parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette matière
j'ai jamais su
[Musique]
regarder
sa crâne elle faut éteindre le feu
c'est dommage pour elle mais j'ai peur
que du coup ça s'effondre
ah ouais là on a eu chaud là-bas vous
savez que c'est Made in France et qu'il
faut à peu près 15 heures pour fabriquer
une statuette pour la petite histoire
voilà donc le temps de la cérémonie
[Musique]
et maintenant quelques années plus tard
j'ai son numéro de téléphone personnel
c'est quelque chose
plein les yeux il est à fond sur Cynthia
il est déjà en couple avec elle sauf que
elle elle le sait pas encore tu penses
après ta femme de ta vie non je sais pas
on va pas faire des comètes sur comète
non je sais pas faire des comètes sur
les plans